joining us once again here on the Rich
Eisen showing his 7th season now as the
HC of Stanford football the one and only
David show how are you David
I'm Goodrich I'm gonna set my VCR my DVR
there you go see now you showing your
age I did yeah I'm excited it is really
good David
it really is it's awesome and but you
need you need you need the the stomach
for it it's Stephen King and it's
Stephen King to the to the enth degree
but you just imagine you just showed
your age I say that I say TiVo I say set
that TiVo a lot to my kids and they're
like yeah my kids probably give me the
same look that your kids give you like
what is that so you are ten days away
from home eating ball in Sydney how did
this come about coach it's been a few
years in the making and we've been
excited about it Cal went last year and
played Hawaii in a different stadium and
different venue but we've been talking
to this company for over a year about
doing this game and rice thankfully
they're excited about it also I think
it's an unbelievable cultural
opportunity for our young people to go
experience another culture experience
another country experiencing new animals
and beaches and and then at some point
go down and get ready to play football
game and show continued to show our our
great game to another community and I
think the people they're excited to
learn more about college football and
it's a great opportunity to teach them
so um so it's more so walk me through
when do you get there
when you land in Australia oh that's
tough part which it's taking me about
two weeks to figure this out right so we
leave on Saturday night we get there
Monday morning so we lose the Sunday the
Sunday doesn't exist for us and then we
go through the week and it'll be a
typical week for us it's that we land on
our players day off neither activities
for things them to do things for them to
do we're going to go to to the
University of Sydney which I'm extremely
excited about for our people to meet
young people in Sydney Australia and
kind of commune a little bit we'll do
some charity events and then we'll book
it down to play a game and then we leave
on a Monday and we arrive on a Monday so
we get to live to Monday's we lose a
Sunday going out and we look at two live
two Mondays when we come back Wow so you
you get each the Monday comes back
the back sort of like a boomerang David
yeah exactly sort of yes sort of like
retro reference by you thank you sir
you know I've never been there by the
way but I am mandated as a sports caster
a sports announcer in America I have to
refer to it as Down Under otherwise they
take my card away from me I understand
you're going down under and I look
forward to seeing that and then you come
back after bye and then boom you are
right at of us see how do you like that
part of the schedule with a big huge
pac-12 title implicating game right away
I think it's great for us and this game
kind of plays into that where we come
back we're still not into school so our
guys will come back and have three
complete days to relax and recover and
get back on West Coast time and then
we'll start slowly we'll do kind of
three days of pre USD and then they'll
get another day off and then we'll get
into game week so really we buy some USC
prep when we come back but you look at
the slate of the schedule we are at USC
and at San Diego State and then home
against UCLA so we're starting right off
the bat against three really good
talented football teams well while we're
you mentioned UCLA I'm with David Shaw
of Stanford here in the Rich Eisen show
you're the perfect person to ask this
about Josh Rosen essentially saying that
if you play college football you
shouldn't really be able to be a
full-time student athlete because the
schedules just aren't right yet you
don't have the time to do both up
properly and appropriately and you have
one of the highest standards
academically for you to get kids into
your program what did you think of Josh
Rosen's comments coach well for me I try
not to make it a me versus just Rosen a
Stanford versus UCLA because there are a
lot of young men young women at UCLA
that are balancing it and balancing it
very well and I say young men and women
because to think that the women play
sports that don't put the same time
Innis with the men do is wrong they care
just as much about their sports and just
as much about their academics and that's
part of the things as you learn in
college when you're an athlete is to
manage your time and give everything
appropriately to communicate with your
coaches and your teachers when you have
things that are conflicting so you can
work them out
to use the help that's available to you
on campus you know we make no excuses
about it we try to be the best of both
worlds we we put of course a lot of
demands on our guys but at the same time
for us if you ever watch us practice
you'll see a group of guys come in late
to practice because they're coming from
class because class become comes before
football and then you'll see a group of
guys that leave our practice early to go
if they have an evening class and we
just make sure that while they're there
they get the things they need to prepare
them to play the game at the highest
level so for us I think it's very doable
for both men and women it takes effort
and just like Josh said it's hard and
absolutely it's hard it's not supposed
to be easy it's supposed to be something
that is difficult that not everybody can
do and when you do it and you go through
it you're so glad that you're able to go
to a great university and play the game
at the highest level well I mean knowing
the pro game as well as you do from your
time at the NFL level do you think josh
is going to have some trouble at the
combine and the interview process where
people think that he's not going to be
focused on professional football because
he is talking about being in academia
and having more to do with life that
life is more to do with than just
football do you think he's going to have
a problem with that well I don't think
so I don't think so he's extremely
talented pastors a very talented
football player he's very smart football
player he's very competitive and the
football side of it is there's no
question about it he's elite the other
thing I think he's going to have to
answer for the different things that he
said at different times he's very
outspoken he's very he doesn't mind
stepping out of bounds and that like
everything else that you and I've talked
about going into the draft is now head
coaches and GM's and owners say okay you
know is this the guy that we want
representing us and I think no one no
one around the guy has ever said that
he's a bad kid and I hope people out
there don't misunderstand us Jeff Rossen
is a great kid now he really is he's
just very outspoken so I don't think
he'll have any issues coming into the
NFL Draft David Shaw joining me here on
the Rich Eisen show how is your
quarterback doing how's he doing he's
great he's great you know we were
appropriately concerned I'm coming off
of a major knee injury at the end of the
season in the bowl game in the entire
training camp he has been full
100% I had anticipated maybe giving him
a little bit of rest here there and
midway through training camp he came to
me said coach I'm ready so that you know
let me let me take more reps let me do
more and he's had no setbacks no issues
at all he looks great I'm excited for
him okay do you talk openly about
national championship do you talk openly
about it what do you do with your kids
I don't avoid it I don't avoid it but
our mantra this year is earn everything
you know so if I'm asked the question in
the yeah that's that's our goal is
everybody's cool but we're going to get
what we aren't and it's not going to be
easy and we're after every single play
we have to scratch for every inch that
we get every point that we earn and
every point that we want to keep off the
board if we earn the opportunity to go
the tactical championship and we're
fortunate to win it you know then the
conversations happen but I'm talking
about it
in August never makes it happen so for
us if I massive ask the question I'll
talk about it but otherwise you know
it's about us earning the opportunity to
be to see how good we can be do you look
at look I understand you've got a trip
to make and it's a monster a logistical
situation for the lack of better phrase
which you got going down to Australia
but do you look at film of USC and Sam
Donald right now for our conference I
did that in the offseason okay I went
through our entire conference our entire
schedule looked at a little bit of
everybody off and Steve and special
teams have an idea of who's coming back
we're what we're going to have to do
depending on how well we're playing to
try to beat the teams on our on our on
our schedule but for us right now we're
ready to take it one game at a time it's
a typical standard phrase that we all
say yes but those that live it those
that live it and actually believe it and
do it those are the teams that win so
the thing that we always keep in mind
also is it's been years since anyone's
gone undefeated in our conference it's
hard Washington was one the best plate
teams in the nation last year and they
ran into a buzz saw
USC USC had a couple tough games they're
very talented football team art our
schedule in our conference is is brutal
so you know if you win a big game you
got to come back and play the next week
so it's not just about one game it's
about the whole season yeah I know we
watched we watched their entire
secondary Washington's entire secondary
get drafted and we saw a bunch of pac-12
players get dry
that certainly on that first night David
Shaw joining me here from Stanford on
the Rich Eisen show and you took on
Mitchell true Biscay and that son bull
when did you notice he got inducted on
the Pro Football Hall of Fame after just
one preseason game but coach did you
yeah the the yellowjacket hasn't gotten
there yet yeah there we go Jackie I
heard being FedEx that she should get it
probably sometime today but you know
though through the entire process
you never heard anybody say that he
wasn't really good that he wasn't very
talented you know some said maybe he
shouldn't go high maybe should go high
he's athletic he's poised we put a lot
of pressure on him in the bowl game and
he responded and made some great throws
I think he's going to hate that he's
going to be a typical rookie he's gonna
hash show some flashes because he has
talent and there's still a lot for him
to learn it's still early in his in his
career so we should pump the brakes on
on that bust right we should just pump
the brakes a little bit I think you got
a pump the brakes on everybody every
rookie quarterback this past week and I
didn't watch all the games all I heard
about all these guys are all going to
the Pro Bowl so early early preseason
games a lot of starters didn't play you
know you get to that third preseason
game sometimes those blitz packages come
out and and and we find out that we
minded their that they're rookies but
I'm so excited to see this rookie class
I think there's a really good group of
guys I think they're going to do well
but I wouldn't put any of them we can't
just yet what about McCaffrey here how
are you seeing his development so far
just over the first few weeks since he
left the campus at Stanford coach well
the the word out of Carolina is he's
everything they hoped for and more as
most of us knew he's just a mismatch
she's a mismatch in space he's a
mismatch of the backfield as a pass
catcher he's a mismatch outside as a
receiver a legitimate receiver not just
a running back out flexed out there so I
think they're excited about him he's the
new toy they have they can move a bunch
of a bunch of different places with all
the talent that they have right now here
cam is back throwing now with the first
group so it's an exciting group for him
to join and I know he's really excited
not just about the role that he's going
to play but the guys he's playing with
them guys like Luke Kuechly and those
guys are just phenomenal guys that he's
fit right in with and it should be an
exciting season yeah I know I use
champion it's a bit because that rule
on the NFL that he can't join the team
until the school from which he's
graduating is completely out of out of
out of class and I mean from your
perspective is that a good rule for the
NFL to have so it used to be I think it
used to be because there's a baseball
rule that if you get drafted he
basically you still get to go back to
school and finish on someone else's dime
that rule wasn't in college but now that
we have that rule in college that guys
can take if they leave early they can
get drafted and then come back and we
pay for their school I think now it's
time to change that rule I think the
rule was great before because it was the
best opportunity for these guys to
finish college and not have to try to
come back and pay for it on their own
three four or five years later but now
they don't have to do that now I say
they get drafted let them go you know
when they're done playing great they'll
come back here in the offseason will
come back after they're done and they're
their education will still be paid for
so I think it was a great rule at the
time but I think it's time to change it
last one for you have you spoken Andrew
Luck at all we've we've texted we've
texted back and forth I know he's
chomping at the bit and hopefully at
some point here he'll get it cleared to
start moving around a little bit I know
there's there's no timetable on it
he's just one of those guys that hates
watching football he'd rather play it
but he also knows he can't come back
until he's ready to come back because we
all know when he comes back and he's
healthy he's one of the best plan he is
so when you say he texts you does that
mean it's just breaking news that he
doesn't have a flip phone anymore or
best you can tell do you have a
smartphone now because you're mr.
technology coach you know colleges let's
just say that I can't send them any
pictures um so the flip phone doesn't
take the pictures but he can send and
receive text okay so he's still doing
that okay have you have you what and
what's the latest technology you have
I'm always I'm always curious because
you always have the cutting edge here
robots you have to what else you got out
there in Stanford oh gosh we have a lot
of things we're actually doing a lot of
things for concussion research we have
mouth guards now that track every hit
that guys take okay we can we can
measure the contact that they that they
have done a course of practice
recently like walk me through that so
they put in a mouth guard and there's a
device in the mouth guard or so yeah
there there are different sensors in the
mouth guards to measure impacts so we
can see the the impact that each player
has during the course of a practice and
we're collecting a ton of data and
trying to find the best ways to help
make this game the safest it can be sure
so last one for you then and then and
I'll send you off to Australia so can
you do that in real time like if some
kid gets a big hit you can then go to a
monitor and say your Sat because we just
noticed you hit a certain metric based
on what we just read from your mouth
guard there's a little bit of a time lag
there's a bit of a time lag but in very
short order we can we can find that hit
absolutely all right coach travel safe
look forward to chat with you down the
line I always enjoy our chats I
appreciate it thanks rich you got it
that's David Shaw of Stanford so Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience if you liked that video be sure
to download our app and I'll be sure to
help the NFL figure out what it catches